History has shown us that sometimes the
impossible happens.
Mikhail Gorbachev went from leading of a
Soviet Union,
the face as a North American
multinational company.
Sometimes nothing brings people
together.
Pizza,
so will we ever see something like this
in North Korea?
Well,
listen up.
North Korea is a very,
very poor country.
The available estimates state that their
per capita production value is 50 times
smaller than that of South Korea.
Less than 1000 kilometers of their roads
are paved.
The average life expectancy is the
lowest in the entire region,
and despite having received humanitarian
aid for more than 22 years,
there's still poverty all over.
The country
is not even the west of it.
The worst is a total lack of respect for
human rights.
The North Koreans live under an iron
pans,
dictatorship,
and the police state where political
prisoners amounts to tens and tens of
thousands.
In fact,
according to the United Nations,
there could be between 80 and a hundred
and 20,000 political prisoners in
reeducation camps in North Korea.
The state controls everything,
but hold on just a moment because in
recent years and important change seems
to have occurred in the country a change
that has a lot to do with money,
with commerce into,
with the market.
You see theoretically North Korea as the
last large country,
the last launch state with a communist
ideology here practically everything is
directed,
organized,
manufactured,
and provided for by the state,
including housing,
health,
education,
food,
employments,
access.
True.
This is all in theory and the truth.
The truth is very different.
You see,
the states has a great deal of
limitations.
Basically,
it's becoming less and less able to do
stuff.
Allow me to explain.
Many of the states,
factories and farms productivity levels
are absolutely on the floor and
additionally in many cases,
as a result of very old machinery,
backwoods production methods,
international sanctions,
and even electrical supply problems for
a great part of their time.
Production centers,
they aren't even open.
Did all
of this.
A new private economy has gained
strength in recent years from which more
and more North Koreans now depends in
order to survive and improve their
living standards.
Now,
hold on just a second,
because a private sector in North Korea
with markets and with capitalism,
it sounds pretty,
but you absolutely have to write and
listen to this
new North Korean market.
Yeah,
dvr.
When Kim Jon was officially declared
supreme leader,
that is the absolute dictator of North
Korea on December the 28th,
2011,
many analysts thought that things could
change in the country.
At the end of the day.
This was a generational change that was
bringing a 28 year olds in the power
that 28 year olds who had studied abroad
in Switzerland.
However,
it became clear that some things weren't
going to change.
North Korea's new leader,
Kim Jong UN has turned out to be just as
terrible as his father was.
The purges,
the inhuman punishments,
the rampant persecution,
the leader centered Coulson's.
In short,
you complete control of citizens' lives
have continued to being this regimes
main characteristics,
religion from birth.
You've learned about the Kim family,
learned that they are gods,
that you must be absolutely obedient to
the Kim family.
The elites are treated nicely and
because of that they make sure that the
system stays stable,
but for everyone else it's a reign of
terror.
A doctor who worked at a hospital in
North Korea and now works as a doctor at
a hospital in South Korea,
however they have you a sentence can.
Johnathan came to power.
Something surprising has happened,
dozens of markets when North Koreans
trade privately have opened throughout
the country,
a new class of merchants and
entrepreneurs is growing in North Korea.
In fact,
according to the Career Institute for
National Unification around 1 million
people working directly in these markets
which have already become one of the
main sources of wealth in the country.
Now,
you want me to run during right now,
but Simon,
hold on a second.
How did those markets kind of out?
Well,
let me tell you first that they don't
have the most glamorous or happiest of
beginnings.
You see,
it all started in the 19 nineties when
famine caused by government mistakes,
lack of resources,
weather conditions,
and the collapse of the Soviet Union
reeks absolute havoc.
Tree
midstate,
the between one to 2 million people died
of starvation right at the time when
North Koreans were struggling to
survive.
The first markets arose,
places where people could exchange
anything they could to get resources
with which they could buy food,
realize that if we did nothing,
we would die of hunger.
So we started to trade Ju Yung
suddenly dozens and dozens of markets
appeared throughout the country saving
thousands and thousands of lives.
That's precisely why the regime didn't
persecute to this type of private
activity,
as you might expect.
Kim Jong,
Il,
the current leaders.
Father,
let's just say that sometimes he
tolerated these markets and sometimes he
decided to repress them.
But since Kim Jong Uhm,
came to power,
the number of private markets is
multiplied and satellite images show
that they don't stop growing.
Now the government government's
authorized as many of these markets and
exchange for renting out spaces to the
nutshell.
Yep,
that's right.
The Pyongyang government is taking
advantage of this new private economy,
but well,
how much?
Well,
according to the Career Institute for
National Unification is calculations.
They get more than 220,000 American
dollars per day,
so precisely for this reason recently
the government isn't only promoting
these markets,
but it's also granting visas to many
Chinese entrepreneurs and traders to
further stimulate this economic
activity,
but to you it does not end that because
while listening to this,
it's only the activity of regulated
markets that's growing.
It's also of the unofficial markets.
That is those that don't have the
authorities official approval,
the black market.
Seeing this all works in the following
way,
in an economic parallel to the public
sector.
People can make everything.
They can choose sweets,
clothes and naturally they tried to sell
these products in the market and to get
money and the currencies,
they're hoping for probably 10 or even
American dollars,
but even so,
it's estimated that 80 percent of the
product sold in North Korean markets
come from China.
In other words,
illegal trade,
which happens behind the government's
back also crosses the border.
It's crossing the border in huge and
ever growing volume.
Many of these unofficial markets are
becoming a window to the outside world
for many North Koreans because Dvo in
these places,
you can even buy a usb stick full of a
foreign movies and shows including
Hollywood productions.
We saw four and programming.
We had to close all the doors and
curtains and pretend that there was
nobody home.
Dan became so you might be wondering,
well,
contraband crossing borders,
why aren't gods in the security services
doing something about this?
Why are they tolerating this illegal
trade?
Well,
basically for two reasons,
the
is that in Pyongyang there doesn't seem
to be much pressure to combat these
markets and we're going to see wine and
moments and seconds because the soldiers
and border guards are also a part of the
business and sometimes even lends a
hand.
That's right.
A common method of payments according to
many of the traders who now live outside
of North Korea,
is to deliver packs of cigarettes
stuffed with money to the police and
soldiers.
While the fact is that these
international merchants byproducts in
the North Korean authorized markets or
the black market and then transfer them
to try and sell them and with that money
they buy Chinese products and take them
back to North Korea to sell.
It's the process as oldest
self
and here within this world of
international trade is where a new class
is emerging.
Individuals who usually have power or
influence or dealings with high
officials who were making serious money
and by the way that driving a lot of
activities that have nothing to do with
the old socialist model within Pyongyang
itself.
The salary for doctors,
it was about 3,501 a month.
That was less than a cost by one
kilogram of rice.
So of course being a doctor was not my
main job.
My main job was smuggling.
At night I would send herbal medicine
from North Korea into China with the
money I would import home appliances
back into North Korea.
Rice cookers,
no tells,
LCD monitors,
that kind of thing.
A doctor who worked at a hospital in
high San North Korea is an anecdote
today,
for example,
you can buy coca cola in the streets of
Pyongyang and according to the South
Korean intelligence service,
at least 40 percent of all North Koreans
participate in private activities and
businesses in some way.
That might be surprising to you,
but there's still more here.
But before we get into all of that is an
important note.
We're talking about a very incipient
process in North Korea.
The government still controls virtually
everything.
If these black markets are growing,
it's because they're being allowed to
grow.
This is likely because they're more
efficient.
They work,
that's a.
They give the government money and they
allow North Koreans to find a way to
improve their living standards.
Something very similar happens in the
Soviet Union and in Vietnam and of
course in China.
So now let's have a look at what else is
happening.
Reforms made in China,
class of merchants and entrepreneurs
that is emerging as a name among North
Koreans,
the Dome Jew,
and as you can imagine,
many of them,
especially those who really make money
are people who belong to the Communist
Party,
ends are well connected in the
government
to say they aren't a part of the elite
which they take advantage of,
not only need to get special treatment
from the security forces,
but also to reach advantages.
Agreements with public companies.
There are clear suspicions that many
irregular exports are manufactured by
public companies,
but the benefits go to these elite
members.
However,
this new economic approach isn't
something that bothers the Pyongyang.
Governments,
in fact,
everything indicates that the North
Korean government wants to reproduce the
Chinese model in some way.
That is to seek foreign investment that
will allow them to grow and develop that
without losing political control.
See,
since Kim Jong came to power,
his government has granted more freedom
to public companies so that they can
organize as they wish and to find their
own suppliers and customers.
It is also promoted,
as we've seen private markets.
They turned a blind eye to the black
markets and families and collective
funds now have individual plots assigned
to them who's harvest once they meet the
state.
Criteria can be used as they wish.
They can of course then sell it in the
private market.
North Korea has even started talking
about special economic zones,
but I must stress here that this is all
a very new process.
This doesn't mean this.
A radical change is going to happen in
the short term.
That's due to the official systems in
capacity.
The North Koreans are developing an
alternative to improve their standard of
living and even though unfortunately
North Korea is still the totalitarian
and poor country that it was before Kim
Jong Un's arrival.
You contemplate that this new kinds of
parallel economy's growth is somewhat
surprising.
That now is your sound.
Do you think that North Korea will try
to follow the Chinese model?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed that video and please
do hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for brand new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcasts they
provided the vocals in this episode
went,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
Sometimes nothing brings people
together.